Are we about to do thoughts, right? Yes, we are. Okay. Three, two, one. Hey,
I'm Janet [inaudible]. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today we're talking about well change really, or what,
what looks like change.
So you remember back to the baboons where we started this program? Yeah.
The question we were asking them was, will those baboons,
if they do enough generations, will they create a new culture and let's stick.
Will it stick? Let's hope. Let's hope. But we don't know. No.
And the town that chooses a mayor,
is that town expanding the sense of possibility or is this a little blip?
Exactly. But now let's get really serious.
There are indeed changes that do stick and we're going to examine or rather
start thing example of that right now. Yeah. Um, but to do that,
we need an evolutionary biologist and we found one at Duke University.
You guys talk to each other now? Yeah. Hello? Hello. Who's this?
That's Brian Hare. Fantastic.
And the first thing Brian here did was tell me about another guy,
Dimitri [inaudible].
Dimitri Dimitri [inaudible] was a very famous geneticist in Russia.
He was, uh, alive during World War II and doing a genetics work.
But after World War II, uh, he was a little spot of Trump. Wow.
What'd he do? Well,
because he was a real Darwinian and he believed in evolution and genetics.
But thinking about evolution, like a Darwinian evolution is,
does that was not popular in Stallings?
Russia is popular the word or was that it? Was that a death sentence?
It was a destiny.
So the writing was on the wall and he knew that he should probably take the
Trans Siberian railroad from Moscow quickly, uh, quickly.
And he went to Novas a beers. And the way that Dimitria bill,
I have decided to hide his continued interest in studying Darwinian evolution
was he would begin a Fox farm where he would make for coats.
So what is Mr Biala actually doing?
What Dr [inaudible] was actually interested in was to understand how does
domestication happen? That's his question.
That's a dumb question. No,
it's not a dumb question at all because you bring that note.
You think about a wild animal. It is impulsive. It is aggressive.
It gravel. What is it? A Wolf you're playing there?
That's a wolf that I've got there in the backyard.
Now this is a domesticated version.
The nature of the animal has completely changed here.
And if you want to learn something about the nature of a creature,
how it can change. Domesticated animals are a wonderful place to start.
So belief he decided,
why don't I just experimentally domesticate some animals?
And his cover was that he was going to make better for coats. When was this,
by the way? 1959 okay,
so Sputnik was up Russians for feeling good and he was making for coats,
so to speak, so to speak. Began one of the most exciting experiments in biology.
So here's what Dimitri Herbalife does.
He goes to a bunch of fucks farmers and he said, look,
I want to buy a bunch of foxes. And he says, well,
all I do is take this group of foxes and break them into two groups and one
group. I'm not going to change them in any way. Okay?
So it's like a control line. So one group is just normal fox normal,
but the other line I'm going to decide who is going to be allowed to breed and
who is unfortunately going to be a fur coat.
So some of the faxes get to have puppy foxes of their own and some foxes become
news. So what he did in the test was marvelously simple. He would go,
or what if his assistants would approach in case where the Fox was kept a baby
fall, sort of a juvenile fox. The experimenter would stand,
say a foot away and would just try to touch the Fox.
I hated the Fox run fox run.
But if the Fox would make this kind of sound and sort of cower in the corner
like most foxes would do, what does that,
what's the sound that is the sound of Fox meets when it's frightening. Really?
Yes. Frightened flux. So what happens if it makes that sound? Well,
they did not breed that Fox in the next generation or to put it in another way,
they kill that pretty much. Yes, that's just wrong.
But now every so often, like maybe one out of every 20 foxes,
there would be a Fox that would not run back, would not,
so it wasn't afraid then.
Then they would choose that Fox to breed in the next generation and they did
this over and over again. Generation after generation,
they would breed the nice foxes together.
Get rid of the bad fox breed the next set.
Get rid of the bad foxes breed. The next set. Next set. Next set.
Next set. Next set guy. Right. What happened in the aunt will eventually eat.
They had foxes that were attracted to humans. Now Jed,
how long do you think it would take to get foxes from being wild,
ferocious animals to being animals who would lick your face after this?
Kind of like an exterminating reading. Yes,
I've taken breeding techniques a long, long time.
I mean now like how many years? You? Many years. How many years? Well,
it took the wolves like thousands of years to become dogs. I Dunno,
I mean long time. Well, here's this. Here's the thing. 10 years is the answer.
10 years now. 10 don't tell me to shut up.
I'm telling you it's 10 years. But now here's the crazy thing.
What was exciting and surprising was that these same foxes,
they actually show a whole suite of changes that he did not select for on
purpose. Like what do you mean physical changes? These foxes,
as they became more gentle for some accountable reason,
their ears instead of pointing straight up, flipped over. That's right.
It was a big accident that they now have floppy ears.
The tales on a Fox, which in a wild fucks, they're straight.
Now they have curly tails.
They have multicolored that are no longer just grade tips of their paws lose
color.
The teeth gets smaller and their bones became very thin.
Their bones got thinner. Yeah. Yes.
So what happens to the skull and the face is it actually becomes more feminine.
The whole animal becomes more delicate than we're puppy. Like wow,
I did sir.
I don't know what to make of that yet. And it's not over.
This experiment has been going on. It's now been 50 years,
45,000 foxes later, 5,000 and Brian, by the way,
he who has read about this is that I got to see this for myself.
So he went to the Novosibirsk just to check.
I did. I took the Trans Siberian Railroad, which you know,
two days of looking at green grass and there's like one species of tree and I
think there was a butterfly that was kind of pretty and was at birch trees.
You're looking at British tree, then another birch tree,
then another birch tree and pretty much by the book you got it. You got it.
You got it, you got it. So I show up and they had thousands of foxes,
giant buildings that are probably, you know,
as long as a football field full of just rows and rows of foxes.
And when you see them, they actually wag their tail.
They whine like a puppy dog.
Oh,
they're cute and cuddly and they love people and they don't bite.
So it sounds perfect except for the one thing I forgot to tell you is that when
they're yapping and excited to see you, they cannot help but pee for sure.
Joel, as I do when ever I see you.
What I don't understand though is it makes sense to me that they're getting
nicer because they're breeding them to get a nicer,
but why is all this other stuff happening to their bodies? What's going on?
Hi. Well, you know, yeah, this is the unsatisfactory answer to that problem.
Nobody really knows why, but okay, I'm rolling on my end.
This is to come suffrage.
Here's a synchronize sync and evolutionary biologist at the University of St
Andrews in Scotland and he has a notion, my hypothesis for what's going on here,
and this is just a hypothesis. Here's what he told me.
Did you guys go back to when a fox has a very, very little itty bitty thing,
an embryo inside its mother's womb, very, very, very early embryo,
like two months old to become a Fox that can survive in the world.
This little embryo needs to grow strong teeth. Yup. It has to grow for need.
The for cancer, having bone strong bone, the bone needs to grow,
blends and needs to grow hormones and all of these things that you need as an
adult Fox,
all of them come from the same founder population of cells in an embryo. Wow,
I didn't know that. Yeah. They called neural crest Xero.
When the Fox grows in these cells, they're doing these epic migrations.
These guys are like pioneers that are,
that are moving throughout the body and glazing these trails all over the place.
Some of them go out into the skin.
Some of them go up into the cartilage of the foxes ears.
Some of them go into the job and they form all these different tissues.
T tail, big parts of the nervous system,
major parts of the brain and the adrenal glands.
What's the adrenal gland? Well, that's the most important one for our purposes.
The adrenal gland pumps out when to be afraid.
Ah, your adrenal glands say, what am I running with?
[inaudible] that makes the fox go, whatever that sounds like.
It's the one that makes that sound.
So when you're breeding fear out of an animal,
maybe what you're doing is you're slowing down
the migrations of these cells.
They don't deliver the fear and that they don't deliver all the other things
that they usually do. What you're focusing on,
what you as the experiment are doing is saying,
I want the guys whose adrenal glands don't mature quickly that might have the
function of making the animal more tame.
But what you're doing as a byproduct of that is selecting for guys who don't get
as many of those cells into their ears and don't get as many of those cells into
their skin and don't get as many of those cells into their teeth.
So if you get some of the cells you need to make your ears for in straight but
not quite enough, then your ear,
it'll go up to a certain point and since the cells aren't going to complete the
deal, the rest of your ear flops over. Really? Yeah.
You haven't come because dogs have little floppy yabbies because the cells have
been slowed down to the point where they don't finish the job.
They were there. They are literally arrested. Bingo.
The argument is that actually when you select against aggression in animals,
you're changing the timing and the rate of development such that the
experimental foxes are actually frozen as juveniles.
They actually never really grow up
[inaudible].
So then to domesticate a file
[inaudible]
just like to domesticate a wolf into a dog.
What you're doing is you're making them permanent puppies.
It's a Peter pan kind of thing. They just [inaudible].
So if we wanted to apply this to to us and we want it to say breed a gentler,
sleeker human being, yeah, we should just kill the football players.
Is that the idea where he would kill the football?
You don't have something against football player? No, actually I like football.
But I mean like with the foxes, you just eliminate the meanings. Oh the me, yes.
With the same thing happened to us. That's where it gets really interesting.
I remember the professor, we interviewed him a few hours back.
A Richard Wrangham vividly. Well, um, when we think about humans,
obviously we're getting, you know, just super speculative, but he says,
if you choose to go back, if we go back just 30,000, 50,000 years,
can you look at the collection of skulls or the early versions of us from way
back then? You see some interesting fucks like changes. Well,
if you look at a domesticated animals,
they have smaller teeth than the wild ancestors.
And in humans we've been getting smaller teeth over the last few tens of
thousands of years. Josh,
like the Fox, we've been getting more grass aisle bones. That means to say that,
um, for a particular length of limb bone, it becomes a little bit narrower.
So it is tempting to think that the same kind of processes been going on in
humans as has been going on in domesticated animals,
which is that there has been natural selection in favor of a kinder,
gentler human, always thickened endo. Who's doing the selecting?
In the case of the foxes,
Mr BLF shuck you if you were too aggressive.
Who's selecting the, who's domesticating the humans? Well,
one idea that has been specifically suggested is that a,
it was the growing tendency for our hunter gatherer ancestors to settle down in,
um, in stable
camps. Do you mean like summer camps?
Let's sing songs around the mile. I'm talking about communities. Look,
if you are in a very small family group,
well then it pays to be big and strong and mean.
Because if you're the biggest guy and you meet a smaller guy and he's got some
potatoes, you grab him, eat his potatoes,
beat him up and then move on to the next till you never have to see him again.
But let's say that as time passes,
human society grows a little bit. You form camps,
we might have 30 or 40 people.
That way you can build bigger fires and you can catch more bunnies and you can
defend against enemies. But in this world, if you beat everybody up,
you may not survive that one pitted against anybody else one-on-one.
The big strong mean guys turned on.
We gonna win when big strong mean doesn't win.
And we see this in some primates is when you can start to form coalitions.
When you can start to have multiple individuals who say, hey mean guy, stop it.
Yeah, you're bigger than any one of us,
but you can't take on both of us or all three of us or our whole group.
No,
we've got other males in the community who aren't going to go away and they say,
okay, we're going to deal with this guy,
and then maybe they deal with him by shouting him down,
ostracizing him or even capital punishment
and Richard Wrangham.
His theory is that if that happens enough times to enough bullies who then can't
have kids and spread their genes because they have the unfortunate condition of
being dead,
then we've essentially bred out the more aggressive jeans or we have
domesticated ourselves.
We're really talking about groups versus individuals here and so in a sense I
think we're really talking about the beginning of society and a on a kind of
rule of law in the way that we think of it.
[inaudible]
and this pressure to be a little more gentle and to be a little bit more
cooperative is hasn't gone away.
I think if anything were being selected to work together more.
Okay tip to be able to tolerate being packed in even tighter.
If you put 20 chimps on a jet plane and tried to send them across the Atlantic,
let me tell you that only one or two would walk off that plane alive.
We do this all the time.
We take it for granted as human beings that big groups of people can get along
with one another.
I do think that it's reasonable to imagine that humans have a future of
increasing self domestication.
What I sent you proposing is that as the earth gets more crowded,
all the creatures on earth,
or at least ascension creatures have to start learning to live with each other
to the mark because they keep bumping into each other.
The winners will be the domesticated ones.
Everyone will get more empathetic to each other because that's the only way you
survive. Let me get gentler and gentler and gentler to lambs.
Literally lie down with lions. You said it beautifully.
Uh,
what do you do? You believe it? Well,
we may have to go through one or two ups and downs before we get the,
and of course there's something slightly alarming about the fact that, um,
one possible mechanism by which domestication has happened in humans is through
literally execution of the more aggressive types,
but in the long term. Sure.
Let's hope that all of us become more,
most sloppy is exactly
like patches on the ends of our tails.
Remember when the new police started working together? Now you have, oh my God,
we've investigated. Yes.
You have to have noticed your years have been looking at these different,
easily. Show me your teeth. Smile.
Anyhow, we should go to reg or not. Just go to the big break. Yeah.
Just the break that exists between us and everything else. Yes.
Let's listen to the way we ended all. Bye.